when did biohacking like became become a
word or a thing
we've always been doing but we gave it a
name i mean if you look at
our ancestors the animal kingdom as well
has been relying upon
you know plants root barks leaves
supplementing with certain things can
certainly fall under the category of of
using certain hacks to
adjust your biology which is basically
what biohacking is you know since the
40s we've known that
you know i'm just going to use a far out
example here like
sunlight on a man's balls can increase
libido and testosterone right so
now these days we have all these people
today to my boyfriend
do some perineum tanning but now now we
have all these these red light
technologies that joking aside you know
when
a man uses you know like 10 to 20
minutes of like
uh you know a mix of of of different
red lights like infrared light you know
on his gonads you actually see an
increase in
testosterone and blood flow and so you
know that it's something our ancestors
were done with the sun and now we're
doing it
with red light panels this podcast
exists because i love talking to people
and i love going deep the purpose
is to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability and what you realize is
that we
are so much more alike than we are
different to quote ramdas
we're all just walking each other home
and this show
is just one step i'm danica patrick and
i'm pretty intense
welcome back to the pretty intense
podcast on the show today is ben
greenfield
for any of those people out there who
have been doing any biohacking
or heard about it you probably have
heard of ben greenfield
he is a human performance consultant
he's a speaker a new york times
best-selling author of
17 books i have his book boundless
and let me just tell you it's kind of
like the bible of biohacking
having just done the interview wow
whatever he's doing to biohack his
mental clarity is working because he was
so
sharp like i would ask a question and he
would not only answer the question but
other
questions and give stories and examples
and i can tell
how maximized he is and so
a lot of the interview we we talked
about you know biohacking itself where
it came from what it's meant to do
genetics and all of the things that
contribute to the person that we are
it was an incredible interview so much
information and there's no way we can
possibly touch
all of his his areas of expertise and
experience
um so get his books for that but but
today was a really really good it was a
really good deep dive on
you know the background and the
understanding of uh
of our body how it works and what we can
do to maximize it
so enjoy the episode and don't forget
get a pen and paper because you're going
to want to write some things down
i know that this podcast is probably all
about driving race cars right
oh yeah that's the only thing i want to
talk about i it's the only thing i know
about
well let me tell you this i went to race
car driving school
okay new jersey so um
i probably and and i'm just throwing
this out there but i probably could go
head-to-head
with you and give you a really good run
for your money because
i trained for a solid two days um
most of it's sitting in a classroom
looking at a whiteboard while staring
wistfully out of the actual cars and
wishing i was driving those
uh but but i'm pretty sure i've got all
the race car driving chops i would ever
need
to give you a run for your money so i'm
just throwing that out there it's kind
of like since i have your book
i feel like anything there is to know
about
hacking my life i'm i'm just uh i'm
pretty equipped by now
it's probably very very very similar
well just if you've ever gone out to a
restaurant to eat
then uh then you're likely uh well on
your way to becoming a nutritionist
i would say that that's probably pretty
big pretty good corollary to my race car
driving experience
so there you go however if you're a
doctor
they don't barely teach you anything
about nutrition in school isn't that the
case
yeah you know you hear some people say
that physicians get two days some people
say physicians get two weeks i think
it's a little bit unfair
to the medical community actually
because you know let's face it doctors
are studying microbiology and
biochemistry and chemistry and could
probably pick apart
the molecular constituents of like a
steak better than many
nutritionists could yet at the same time
when it comes to
applying what i would what i would call
just just like a real
functional holistic aspect of nutrition
to healing
you know oftentimes that's that's
overridden by the concept that
you know a pharmaceutical for example
can
affect just as good if not greater
change which i
don't think is the case however i i do
think that doctors
do even if they maybe maybe don't
know it know a lot more about about
nutrition and nutritional chemistry than
the general public and most
nutritionists and
registered dietitians and furthermore
like i know a lot of really good docs
who have done a ton of continuing
education
after medical school so maybe they
didn't learn in medical school but they
learned it after so i think it just kind
of depends on on the physician but
i never want to be the guy who just like
throws all doctors under the bus and
you know says they don't know anything
about diet so
yeah but i suppose it could be
imaginable that if you're
interested in the human body which a
doctor must have must have a level of
interest in the human body
then it's imaginable that they would be
interested in what goes into the body
so by nature they have a curiosity
probably
yeah let's hope let's hope at least
um what uh speaking of curiosity uh
i mean it's a really probably a very
basic question
um but i have a follow-up that i'm
really curious about but
i mean what is your fascination with the
body i mean clearly
you have a deep fascination with
performance and uh excellence
and maximizing so like where does that
come from
i i didn't really grow up that
interested in the human body
you know aside from the fact that i
owned one um
i i wasn't too interested in the
mechanics of
how it works uh however
when i was 13 or 14 i discovered the
sport of tennis
and that kind of like pulled me from
being a total geek who was only
interested in like
you know pulling apart the motherboard
on my computer and playing chess and
you know touring around with with
violins and musical instruments and
just you know being a quintessential
homeschooled
geek uh into being a little bit more
interested in
in physical culture so to speak right
like i remember my
dad took me to guard sports down the
street the local sporting goods store
and
you know because i was playing tennis
and i want to get stronger so i got a
set of
10 pound dumbbells i had no clue how to
use them like the first exercise that i
learned
and this was just based on my own like
intuition was i would like lay on my
belly
on my bed and have the dumbbells on the
on the floor and do like basically like
a preacher curl
on my on my stomach while i'd watch tv
just thinking that you know
well at least it's going to give me
strong arms for tennis right and then um
i think the second piece of exercise
equipment that i got
was again i saw this on tv it was like
one of those as seen on tv ab devices
it was that one that you that you put
the pad against your
stomach and kind of pull into your
stomach
doing an isometric contraction to make
your abs stronger
so i either damaged a whole bunch of my
internal organs when i was 13 years old
or else
actually you know worked my core a
little bit but but you know i started
running up the hill back behind my house
and then
you know i had a coach i started doing
sprints and you know i saw my body just
start to
morph which i actually really really
liked um
and i i really liked the effects that
this type of physical training was
having on my
tennis performance and um you know
and then i i got into i got into
nutrition i got more into weightlifting
i uh i don't think this served me too
well
in the whole functional realm of sports
performance but
i was super into rocky so i'd like watch
rocky films
and lift weights and exercise
and i started getting super into it like
even when i was like 14 or 15
um you know my garage gym kind of
morphed into a pretty impressive little
facility
and i i had a few mentors
in later years of high school a guy who
was a
professional bodybuilder who taught me a
whole bunch about nutrition and more
about lifting
another one of my dad's friends was the
washington state powerlifting champ so
he taught me
you know how to clean and how to
deadlift
how to jerk and push press and he taught
he taught me all these moves which
really amplified my performance in
tennis and
it got to the point where i went from
wanting to be
um kind of like an early high school
a computer programmer and video game
designer which
would probably would have made me like a
multi-billionaire by now i'd probably be
like some e-gamer
or or zuckerberg uh
but i instead uh walked on to
the college tennis team and declared a
major
in kinesiology which is basically like
you know glorified personal training but
you know study of biomechanics and and
uh human movement physiology
and then i got i got so into it
especially like that you know like we
were talking about earlier like a
physician will
study a lot of biochemistry and
microbiology and organic chemistry
i got so into that side of of science
after not being that interested in in
science all through high school
um that i i decided i actually kind of
want to be a doctor
and so i took all the pre-meds
um got a master's degree in exercise
physiology and biomechanics
wow you know took the mcat wound up
applying to medical school
got accepted to a bunch of medical
schools and
i actually decided to like take a gap
year
and work a year in the private sector
and and
part of that was because i just want
some time off after education and part
of it was because
i was looking at a couple of md phd
programs
that i didn't get accepted to and i was
kind of kind of pissed off about that
being my little
proud narcissistic college student
itself and so
if you admit it it's okay you're not if
you admit it
yeah i guess so if the narcissist didn't
miss their narcissist they're not a
narcissist exactly
um but then i uh i
my my work in the private sector was i
got a job in hip and knee surgical sales
for this company called biomet and so
you know my job consisted of driving
around the doctor's offices and and you
know scrubbing down and attending at
surgeries with my little laser pointer
showing them where to
you know where to put the overpriced
hips and knees they were implanting in
morbidly obese patients who probably
through preventive medicine
wouldn't have had to overwhelm our
insurance system and
and get get all these implants put into
their body well
these you know rich doctors with their
boats in their cars
complaining the whole time about all the
paperwork that dictated that they didn't
have time to
you know go and enjoy those fancy boats
and cars the whole experience for me
in like modern allopathic medicine kind
of left a little bit of a better taste
in my mouth and so
after like five months in that job i
quit
and kind of got back into health and
fitness which is all i'd done
in college you know i worked as a
personal trainer and a nutritionist all
through college
for timeline purposes like how oh that
was like 2005
or so so um so then
i i literally just like walked to the
athletic club
that was close to the apartment i was
living in and slapped on my resume and
asked for a job
you know i was already a certified
personal trainer and a nutritionist and
that that was
a lot of what i'd done for the past few
years and
um you know i got a job managing that
gym
managed that gym for a couple years and
then eventually
met a local physician and he and i
branched off and started a whole sports
medicine facility where we had
you know massage physical therapy
chiropractic sports performance
uh we had all these high-speed video
cameras to analyze gate
and do bike fits and swim analysis and
run analysis
we had a we had a whole uh
calorimetry lab where we do like vo2
maxes and resting metabolic rates
uh big functional exercise facility so i
i directed that sports performance
facility for about
uh four years and then when my wife
got pregnant with our twin boys kind of
realized that
the uh the the hours that i was putting
in were kind of unsustainable
you know just like waking up at five a.m
to go train clients till
10 a.m and then a couple hours off and
then you know work through lunch then a
few more hours off and then
get home from work at like 9 00 p.m and
you know
check a bunch of emails and you know
work on the computer for a while and go
to bed and
so i i kind of mapped hours of dictating
yeah exactly so so i mapped out this
plan
to um do what was really in my heart
that i wanted to do which was do a lot
more writing
um kind of like leverage my knowledge a
lot more create like
information products books i started a
podcast i started a blog
i started a newsletter um and in 2009
i was voted as america's top personal
trainer
by the national strength conditioning
association and that kind of thrust me
into the limelight of like
traveling around all these conferences
giving talks from stages to personal
trainers about the fitness business
and you know i was kind of making a name
for myself there and so
um so from about 2010 onwards
you know i started doing a lot more what
i do now which is you know i coach and
consult with people from all over the
world about
you know health and performance and you
know sleep gut
you name it and then i do a podcast do a
blog
write books write articles you know do
some investing in the health and fitness
sector
you could have literally turned every
one of these chapters into a book
but you put them all in one book which
is like
so ambitious and so cool and just also
that you know says how much
you wanted to get that information out
there so what was it
when did biohacking like becam become a
word or a thing
do you really like when did biohacking
become a thing that you'd
seek and try and figure out and have we
actually always been doing it we just
gave it a name
yeah it is it's the latter we've always
been doing it but we gave it a name
i mean if you look at our ancestors and
this is interesting i was having a phone
conversation with somebody about this
yesterday
um because they said well i want to do
this and this and this but i don't want
to take
any supplements at all it's like you
know whatever they had you know low
vitamin d
and low red blood cell magnesium and
some issues with with the gut
but they're like you know i just want to
do this through you know food and
movement
which which is kind of laudable you know
want to take a natural approach yet
when you look at our ancestors you know
humankind for all of its existence and
the animal kingdom as well
has been relying upon you know plants
root
barks leaves teas tinctures powders oils
salves you know blends all these things
that we get from nature
the emergence of say um
modern encapsulation technology which
allows us
with a little bit of better living
through science to
do those same things and harness those
same herbs and plants and powders and
extracts etc but in a little bit more of
a
convenient manner doesn't mean that
something like supplementation is
unnatural it's something
that we've done for a long time uh you
know
and in the realm of of biohacking and i
would say
you know in some ways you know
supplementing with certain things can
certainly fall under the category of of
using certain hacks to
adjust your biology which is basically
what biohacking is
um to a certain extent we um
we do that with technology too right
like
you know since the 40s we've known that
you know
i'm just going to use a far out example
here like sunlight
on a man's balls can increase libido and
testosterone right so
i've been recommending that every day to
my boyfriend i'm like let's
just put some sun on your balls do some
perineum tanning
but now now we have all these these red
light technologies that joking aside you
know when
when a man uses you know like 10 to 20
minutes of like
uh you know a mix of of of different
red lights like infrared light you know
on his gonads you actually see an
increase in
testosterone and blood flow and so you
know it's something our ancestors were
done with the sun and now we're doing it
with red light panels and ultimately
for me the initial idea
that there are things that you can do
that go beyond just say like
exercise and nutrition to amplify
muscle growth or recovery or sleep or
gut health or anything else was
something i discovered when i was
bodybuilding
because i had a brief stint for a couple
of years
in college as a bodybuilder so i was
about 175 pounds in college
i got a dare from one of my friends
to sign up for a bodybuilding
competition that was like 11 months away
so i signed up for it and you know just
started
lifting like an animal and you know
downing these man in a can
chemical infused protein shakes like six
times a day and
you know showing up at the gym at four
am before all my classes and
you know downing a bunch of red line or
whatever other
mix of pre-workouts happen to be at the
gym and you know getting my uh
yeah they they work i mean they're
they're essentially uh you know a mix of
you know ephedra and sildenafil you know
basically an
upper with something very much like
viagra for blood flow but you know they
they work they're a fast track to a
heart attack at the gym but they work
um and so i uh i i started bodybuilding
you know just lifting like an animal
so i put on about 45 pounds of muscle
and you know wound up competing uh 215
pounds
and about three percent body fat but
along the way
of course via all these magazines and
old school online forums you know
you i started to delve into you know all
this
bodybuilding lore and literature and i
think bodybuilders when it comes to
the physical culture aspects of
biohacking were some of the original
biohackers as far as like oh here's the
the
pill you pop and here's what you inject
and here's the here's the different
you know creams and powders and you know
everything from
um you know peptides and sarms to
wrapping tourniquets around the muscle
to decrease
blood flow to increase results a lot a
lot of stuff people are
are funny enough just now kind of like
making popular and discovering in the
past five years you know 20 years ago
bodybuilders doing this so so that was
kind of like even though i was a
poor college student all i could afford
was like creatine
and tuna and protein shakes i still
you know paid attention to a lot of that
stuff and then um
you know in in the past
several years biohacking seems to have
just
exploded in terms of a term that is used
to describe a lot of things
that really i don't think are biohacking
right like i don't think
say like um you know let's say
you know putting butter ghee or coconut
oil into your coffee
or going for a walk barefoot in the
sunshine
is biohacking right that's just like
basically a cooking and b walking
outside in the sunshine without your
shoes on it's not bio hacking
but the original biohackers if you
actually look at
kind of the history of biohacking they
were called grinders
right they called their body wet wear
and they would use
technology that they'd call hardware to
amplify
certain aspects of human function so
these would be like the type of people
who
install like a tiny magnet in the chest
that will vibrate
every time that you face true north or
small
magnetic implants in the ears that
enhance hearing
or you might find a you know a story
online about the guy who
injected chlorophyll into his eyeballs
for
night vision um or another example
would be kevin warwick probably original
so-called human cyborg who
literally he and his wife uh installed
like magnetic implants in their fingers
to be able to kind of like that movie
minority report
be able to interact with screens and
technologies and
so that that i really think is like
the true original term of biohacking
literally like a computer hacker taking
apart a hard drive
and amping up the graphics software or
the graphics card
or um you know or defragging a computer
and make it run faster or whatever
you know these people are using like
technology to
literally implant things in the body or
remarkably
and quite significantly alter human
biology in a way that i think is a true
hack i think a lot of what we do now
that we call bio hacking
even though of course the term has
umbrella to cover a lot of different
things
is really just like using smart living
and science to be healthier right so
so yeah i think it's kind of a an
overused term
but i think that the the history of it
is is quite interesting a lot more
fringe and far out and even arguably in
many cases unhealthy
compared to to how modern biohacking
looks
it's similar to like like a ketogenic
diet right
like a modern ketogenic diet of say like
um you know eating a bunch of coconut
oil fat bombs
and you know having chicken wings but no
bread at the steak house
and you know drinking ketone esters and
ketone salts developed for
tour de france cyclists in the u.s
department of defense
is way different than like ancestral
ketosis
that our ancestors would have done which
would have been accomplished through
periods of intermittent fasting or
religious fasting
high consumption of plants and
vegetables and some amounts of
kind of like nose to tail animal
consumption without the introduction of
a lot of starches
and sugars a lot of low-level physical
activity throughout the day
and amplification of blood glucose and
burning fats
through through that type of natural
living versus
you know kind of like modern bastardize
so called dirty keto
where yeah you're in a state of ketosis
but it's not like the healthy form
right so we we humans are able to
bastardize just about anything well it
seems especially once it becomes an
industry
yeah well any any follow the money any
way to monetize something
um it's a guideline too i mean
biohacking is a guideline is something
you know that it can be useful
but i just recently was uh doing a farm
tour
and uh in the farm tour the guy was
talking about
how much of the bio-available nutrition
is lost and as soon as you pick a leaf
off the vine
it's like within the first 15 minutes
you get i don't know
what he said 75 of it or something like
that and then
you know by the time the next days go by
you're down to like 25
of of the actual mineral nutrition
i'm not getting all the words right but
basically the nutritional
value of it it just completely
uh it declines so much and so
when i think about um biohacking it's
like and
and in the way that maybe is not
accurate in describing it it feels like
we're all trying to get back to a state
of
um natural like homeostasis with the
body
than it is that we're trying to somehow
become something above
average elite human we're trying to go
how can we get this body to perform
in the way that it was supposed to
before we had all this other [ __ ] going
on in the world and we
sat next to our phones and we did the
interview on our computer and we've got
wi-fi on our houses and we've got
you know planes flying overhead dropping
things and you know i mean like we've
got
so much environmental going on that it
feels like we're just trying to like
like get back to that state of
well-being that we
maybe used to be in yeah we're
essentially
uh fighting an uphill battle in a
post-industrialized era
against a host of modern assailants that
human biology hasn't had to face
in thousands of years and i'll i'll get
to what i mean by that momentarily
but just real quick what you said about
picking the plant and
the nutrients and minerals potentially
decreasing in density or degrading
pretty quickly after that plant is is
picked that is true to a certain extent
i mean the same
way that if you um you know if you have
a vitamin d supplement
you know you leave it out in the heat
and the light and it oxidizes and
especially become
less effective over time um when
when you look at a lot of packaged and
processed foods
that have sat stagnant you know in
containers often with many preservatives
to
to keep some semblance of them alive or
at least keep you know mold or
or other things at bay there's there's
certainly some truth to that but there's
also truth to the fact
that some things can become more
unlocked
or activated when taken from a vine
or a tree or plant or a root and what i
mean by that
is you know there's a book called eating
on the wild side
by author joe robinson where she
describes how if you're going to have
like a kale salad
the next day or some kind of leafy green
salad you actually see an
up regulation in antioxidants which in
many cases are plant defense mechanisms
if you tear up the leafy green the day
prior to eating it then put it into the
fridge
because the plant thinks it's being
eaten by a wild animal
upregulates its plant defense mechanisms
and then
when you consume it you're actually
getting more of those so-called
hormetic benefits of those plant defense
mechanisms like a lot more of the
concentration
of the antioxidants if it's kind of like
ripped apart and torn apart
prior to consuming or like a like a vine
ripened tomato that you pick like a nice
plump heirloom tomato
you know if you're a guy concerned about
prostate health all the lycopene that
tomato is fantastic for you
but if you like uh skin
and peel and deseed the tomato to get
rid of some of the
problematic lectins in there and then
you cook it
you not only make it more digestible and
more absorbable
but you actually wind up with a greater
concentration of bioavailable lycopene
right and so so some plants you know if
you just
pick them straight from the vine and eat
them versus fermentation soaking
sprouting tearing apart cooking etc
you actually can unlock a lot more from
plants but what i think
you're probably getting at is that the
um dried blueberries coated with
cane sugar and soybean oil that you buy
at the healthy food section
of hudson's booksellers as you're
wandering through the airport
is definitely not going to be as good
for you as like a nice wild blueberry
that you pick as you're wandering
through the forest somewhere so
yeah there's definitely something to be
said for that
but but back to the to the um to the
post industrialization and that's using
something like biohacking
to fight that uphill battle it really is
true like
you know for example water we know that
water as it tumbles over
rocks and underground aquifers and
through springs and gets hit by sunlight
there's actually an electrical charge in
the water that
allows it to be better absorbed by the
body um
it's it's a little bit more of what we
would call live water or water that
that forms what's called an exclusion
zone that allows the water
when it's part of your blood to more
easily travel through vasculature
there's wonderful books about this like
uh human heart cosmic heart by dr thomas
cowan
or understanding the heart by dr stephen
hussey that goes into this idea
of water within the body being more
structured and closer to nature
and the fact is using using a
you know a technology like a like a
structured water filter for example
you can take water that's been sitting
in a well or a cistern or pipes in the
home or in a
in a glass or a plastic bottle and kind
of restructure it by using that
technology so it's closer
to nature so that'd be one example of
using a you know technology
to bring yourself closer to nature like
the example i gave about sunlight right
maybe you can't get out in the sun
because you have you know an office job
and you got to be endorsed for eight
hours a day well maybe you buy
some red lights to simulate
what sunlight does for you even though
you're unable to get outdoors
maybe you can't go outside barefoot
right but you can because you don't want
whatever look like a
dirty hippie walking around the street
or maybe there's needles or
glass on the floor but but you can get
like a grounding mat you can sleep on or
a grounding mat that you can stand on
while you're working in your office and
be grounded
you've got one right there nice
yeah i've got one i've got one beside me
in my office actually there's a like a
mat i stand on that has a wire going up
my office door with the stake that's
planted into the grass
outside natural grounding that works to
stick the stake in the ground
yeah you can also ground into the like
any properly grounded outlet
right that's what mine does i notice
better effects when it's just staked
straight into the ground
um and part of that could be placebo and
i just feel like it's more natural but
either way placebo is effective i mean
placebo is a real effect
oh yeah i mean if it works it works
water light earthing grounding like
we can use technology to bring these
type of things
that might be um less natural in a
post-industrial era right like bottled
plastic water and
standing on carpet inside instead of
being outside
in the sun or or being under modern
fluorescent led lighting versus being
able to go outside
we can use technology such as biohacks
to bring ourselves closer to nature
and kind of have the both best of both
worlds like live in a post-industrial
era
but then also be kind of closer to
nature using
technologies not as an excuse not to you
know go outside and
walk on the beach in your bare feet and
jump in the ocean get in the sunlight
but
as a way to bring some of that stuff
indoors or into a post-industrial
lifestyle
as well and you know you could say
the the same for um
you know for for something like
nutrition like i was talking about with
with you know supplementation
to replace what our ancestors might have
done or you talked about wi-fi and
radiation and airline travel and we
could even do things that
our ancestors never would have had to
have done because they weren't flying in
giant metal tubes 40 000 feet above the
earth but we know that for example high
amounts of radiation
so-called non-natural emf uh
electromagnetic fields they can kind of
damage the cells
they they cause the what are called the
voltage-gated calcium channels and cells
to open up and get a calcium influx into
the cell
and that results in a slightly more
positive charge inside the cell
than would be acceptable for normal
human cellular metabolism at the same
time the same type of radiation
can cause a little bit of dna damage and
accelerate aging
and and the protein folding mechanisms
in your body in a similar respect so
when i fly
you know for example i can take a
supplement like uh
like nad right which is a common
anti-aging molecule used to repair dna
and take more of that when i fly
preferably paired with something else
that allows the nad
to repair the cells which would be
something called a sirtuin like
resveratrol or wild blueberry powder
or any of the dark purples and
and reds and blues that we might find in
nature or in supplement form
i can take magnesium right to help
offset
some of that calcium influx into the
cell
and i can even use something like uh
let's say
again i'm on an airplane i'm flying i
don't want the airplane food i want to
shut down some of the inflammation
i talked about those ketones earlier
right i can take a shot of ketone
esters or or a supplement like ketone
salts
and that further can help to mitigate
the inflammation and also keep me from
you know stuffing food in my face when
that airplane meal comes by and i've got
nothing to do and i'm bored so
why not eat you know the ketones just
take away all hunger
so that would be an example of
biohacking flying with nutrients right
you get on flight you have nad
you have magnesium you have ketones you
feel a lot better when you land
especially if you can you know get
outside barefoot or travel with one of
these grounding or earthing mats
and so that's an example again of what
we could probably call
biohacking right like better living
through science to live healthier
in a post-industrial era full of modern
assailants that
could harm our biology but if that if we
do the right things
is going to have a lot less of a
dramatic effect upon our day-to-day
function
i'm just curious your perspective on
aging is there is there a certain point
in time where we're supposed to release
this sort of
expectation level of being a certain way
looking a certain way
feeling a certain way or essentially
is there a belief that you can kind of
hack your way to uh
you know the fountain of youth of life
for
a very long time the the modern
anti-aging and longevity
movement is kind of interesting because
i think on one hand
we have like the transhumanists who want
to live forever or at least live until
they're 180 or
200 or 220 or whatever and
um you know these are the type of folks
who might be looking at
at things like you know crier
preservation of their head when they die
so that
when we're able to plant that brain and
head on a new body they will go on to
live in eternity you know and that's
under of course the assumption that the
the seed of consciousness and life
itself is in the brain which
i don't think it is but it's an
interesting thought um
and people who are spending like half
their lives
cold and hungry and libido-less and
fasting
and doing cold baths and you know
sleeping at night in a hyperbaric
chamber instead of with their loved one
because they just want to live forever
and
you know i think that that form of
life extension and a focus on anti-aging
is unhealthy and is unrealistic versus
embracing
embracing death in the natural life
death cycle and honoring death and
recognizing death is simply
the the passage into the the next step
of
life and so i'm i'm definitely not in
kind of like the transhumanist
sector when it comes to anti-aging and
longevity yet at the same time i think
that by taking steps
to simultaneously increase or improve
both your lifespan and your health span
you can equip yourself to be more
impactful
and more purposeful each day with the
years that you have been given
you can equip yourself to not only be
more present in relationships or
with your grandkids or with loved ones
or active in the local community when
you're
you know 80 or 90 or 100 when others who
might not have done the same things
might be you know kind of relegated to a
wheelchair
or in a nursing home when they're when
they're 70. so there's the impact
and the purpose part of things um and
then there's just the fact that
you know when when you're engaging in a
lot of these
anti-aging and longevity tactics like
say
you know using nad or
getting out in the sunshine or using
earthing and grounding technologies or
drinking
better water or even doing things like
you know stem cell or exosome infusions
or some of these more fringe things
as long as they're not in my opinion
taking up a disproportionate amount of
time
and energy again back back to the ironic
nature of like doing so much to live a
long time that you're spending half the
time that
you'd be living longer just doing things
to make you live longer
but as long as as you're reasonable and
responsible in your approach
i think that really the beauty of a lot
of these anti-aging and
longevity tactics are a equipping
yourself to have better health span and
lifespan so you can be more impactful
with the purpose and the skill set that
god has given you during this time that
you are on the planet
no matter how long that time is whether
it's 70 or 80 or 90 or 150
you know it's about impact and purpose
and being fully functional
and then b this is the part that you
know i recently addressed this on a
beauty and
anti-aging podcast that i did with a
local uh
um physician who does things like you
know
hair treatments and prp for the face and
wrinkle treatments and
you know working on symmetry and beauty
of the body i think that
having a certain amount of pride in your
image
and how you look as you age is
reasonable you know and i'm not i'm not
a fan of like
you know let's say women who are six
years old
walking around looking like they're
trying to be 20 year old college
students i think it
often just pulls off a look like a a lot
of these women they just almost look
like old hookers
but you know just like you know fake
boobs and the botox treatments
and the clothing that really is more
appropriate for someone who's 40 years
younger
i mean i think that that that aspect of
the beauty movement
is again like fear of death running from
the changes that you should be accepting
as honorable changes for your body
and just the shift into another chapter
of life but at the same time
like i think you can be beautiful and
handsome and symmetrical
and well kept and well put together as
you age
due to a lot of these things like say
maybe doing a clay mask every week and
doing some
derma rolling or micro needling for your
scalp or making sure that you stay
fit and symmetrical and working on
mobility and doing all these things to
stay kind of
put together and even arguably beautiful
as you age
and i think that that's good because it
gives you self-confidence
i think it shows that you care for and
respect the body
that you've been given and let's face it
if
you're in this to fulfill maslow's
hierarchy of needs to care for your
family to feed yourself to make an
income etc
we know that people who care for
themselves they you know they tend to
get paid more they tend to get hired in
better positions they tend to get
respected more they tend to get taken
more seriously
so you know i i certainly think that
there's
something to responsible embracing of
the beauty
movement in anti-aging as well i think
it all depends on the lens through which
you view these things and the reason in
your heart
that you're doing them and if it is
noble and sound
and to be able to be more impactful and
make other people around you feel more
comfortable
and to have more self-confidence in
yourself you know i love a lot of these
tactics and
you know i was originally what boundless
was gonna be like i sat down to write
that book three years ago
as a book on anti-aging and longevity
and
you know as you can see the chapter on
anti-aging and longevity in that book is
like 150 pages long
but the you know i realized that there's
just so many pathways
that you have to take care of if you
want to age gracefully like the immune
system
and the gut and the brain and the
muscles
and the lymph and you know all these
different factors that
the book kind of morphed into just an
all-encompassing blueprint for the human
body
with certain chapters on longevity but
you know that was originally i was super
interested in that book just being about
anti-aging and longevity and realized
you really can't so much more take that
without addressing everything else
so much more uh genetics
i feel like as these things come up a
lot of people want to make an excuse
about
um you know well i've bad genetics or
look at my parents or whatever but of
course as science
moves on we learn about epigenetics and
we learn
how i mean our our dna is changing all
the time so
is this a viable excuse or
reason is it a reason or an excuse
genetics
um it's a great question
so it's it of course returns to that you
know
classic analogy of being someone who's
holding dynamite
but the dynamite is not going to harm
you unless you also
light a match and i i've actually never
held dynamite and lit it so i'm i'm kind
of just going off what other people tell
me
but you know if you have a match and you
strike it you like the dynamite then it
becomes an issue right
and so yeah like for me personally
i discovered several years ago through
23andme genetic testing
which i don't think is the gold standard
for genetic testing i actually like one
called strata gene
which really identifies the most
problematic genes that you really should
care about and dress
versus a whole laundry list of genes
that just make you lay awake at night
and worry
but i i found that i had a significantly
higher risk for two things type 2
diabetes and colon cancer
right i also found out relatively
useless information like
what my eye color was and you know
whether or not i was predisposed to
you know i guess it's somewhat useful
like oxidizing coffee faster
but but the the big ones are like
chronic disease risk factors that you
can look at
and then yeah you you could just get
super scared
and use that as a way to worry yourself
into oblivion or ironically worry
yourself into the disease that you've
just found out that you have
a higher percentage of getting but then
in my opinion if you're willing to take
actionable steps towards reducing your
risk for said disease
genetic testing is highly valuable in my
case
when i saw that i had a higher than
normal risk for type 2 diabetes
i very much began to study uh you know
ways that you can manage things like
pancreatic function and insulin
sensitivity and i began to wear a
continuous blood glucose monitor just to
kind of know
how often during the day my blood
glucose was going up and down i began to
be more cognizant of
looking at labels and in particular for
me paying attention to
some of the sugar and carbohydrate
content of the meals i
began to do things like you know on on
days in which i knew i was going to eat
more
carbohydrates or more sugars doing
things like cold thermogenesis or you
know cold showers or
cold baths or you know going swimming in
a cold body of water
and doing weight training which very
quickly depletes the muscle glycogen
levels and
restores insulin sensitivity i began
using compounds like
apple cider vinegar and ceylon cinnamon
and
bitter melon extract before meals to
stabilize my blood glucose
and as a result i've become far
healthier
and my risk for that type 2 diabetes to
manifest
is arguably much lower because i'm
using the genetic data to inform myself
and take actionable steps
not just worry right and so i also uh
you know actu actually prostate and
colon cancer were two of the risks that
were high for me so so i actually am
careful to do things like i was talking
about like
you know lycopene for example from fresh
tomatoes um
not to freak anybody out but i even do
like you know i do
uh coffee enema you know a couple of
times a month and
sometimes even once a week to take care
of my colon health
i know that sounds fringe but but you
know it's something that i'm comfortable
with
and so you know i'll do everything from
from the mild lifestyle practices to
things that people might block out like
a like a coffee enema but but
i use that information to care for my
body properly
and so yeah i think if you use it
properly genetics can give you a genetic
testing in particular and give you a lot
of
actionable information and so you know
same thing with my kids they've both
been tested
they neither of them they're twin 13
year old boys produce
appreciable amounts of glutathione
endogenously which is a very potent
antioxidant
which they actually need and so they
supplement
with glutathione in the mornings they
also have one of the genes responsible
for
lowering or allowing them to not produce
as much brain derived neurotrap
neurotrophic factor bdnf which like
miracle grow for the brain
now two ways to increase bdnf actually
three good ways to do it are
regular sauna uh and aerobic exercise
and lion's mane mushroom extract my kids
actually take lion's mane
several mornings of the week they hit
the sauna two or three times a week to
do like some breath work and different
things i've taught them how to do in the
sauna
and they have little workouts that they
do that include elements of aerobic
fitness because i know
i'm giving them a step up in life early
in life because
they know their genetic blueprint and
the steps they take each week
can help that genetic blueprint to
manifest in better ways
wow wow i i mean how fascinating to see
how a generation of those kids are going
to become as adults
um you know we might we might start
living to 125 naturally who knows
um so let's say somebody wants to
because you were talking about a lot
about testing and different things and
and i think it's such a cool resource we
have now with technology to be able to
um have this accessible to anybody
through the mail essentially
uh so what if i've i mean i'm so
fascinated with the body
i have been working out since i was 14
years old and especially being in sports
and
everything from physical performance to
mental performance
uh but i i mean i'm always curious about
god what is the best diet for me when's
the best time to eat because like
intermittent fasting's really screwed me
up because i don't like to be hungry and
i like
i'm like one of those rare people that i
feel worse
usually when i work out if i haven't ate
than if i do i feel great if i do
um so i'm like when do i eat what do i
eat uh and then how do i work out and
what's too much and so
let's say you're some this is this is
i'm probably the norm right am i i mean
i feel like i would be the normal person
it's like what do i when do i eat it and
how do i work out
um maybe breaking maybe we have to break
it down into two different ways but
what are the testing protocols that you
would recommend
that are the most beneficial to figuring
to like the first
step in there and i know hormones are a
thing and i it's actually to ramble on
um i've been been doing hormone testing
um like every two weeks for for six
weeks and
uh learning more about myself and like
the fact that i have a like a low
thyroid and
you know trying to fix that kind of
thing so i i mean hormone testing seems
like
one of them for sure uh but what other
kind of testing
would you recommend and even for
hormones maybe of course
i'm sure i think you have the dutch test
you said that's a really good one
um but where do where does someone start
and i don't mean like
maybe maybe there's like a bare minimum
like what's the
entry level but i'm kind of more curious
about like
level two or three here right kind of
like full optimization yeah
i love that question and it's it's
insightful because
it acknowledges the fact that we are you
know there's a great book about this by
a guy named roger williams called
biochemical individuality we are all
biochemically individual
we have different vitamin d excretion
rates we have different
uric acid excretion rates and responses
to higher or lower levels of protein
intake
we have different size stomachs
different size livers and different
sized pancreas as you read this book
it's
great because these illustrations like
12 different liver shapes and sizes and
and then we have all the genes that we
just talked about and
you know this basically dictates the
fact that
what works for one person especially
nutritionally is not going to work
for another and it also makes quite
shameful the fact that
you know in the nutrition industry the
you know the
the dirty dark secret is that if you
want to make a lot of money you write a
book
and you write a book that's a diet book
and you say that
you proclaim that this diet is the best
diet for all of humankind and you sell a
lot of books
and unfortunately that diet might work
for a small subset
of individuals you brought up the
example of
you said screwing yourself up with
intermittent fasting well like 80
percent of the research that's done
on fasting or human science in general
is done on men
not women and while we know that a 12 to
16 hour daily intermittent fast
is actually quite good for cellular
autophagy or cellular cleanup or
longevity or better better anabolic
function or better fat burning
efficiency in a male population
women uh have a hormone called kispeptin
that is released premenopausal women
that is responsible for
inducing the release of things like
follicle stimulating hormone and
luteinizing
hormone and a lot of the elements
responsible for normal fertility
and normal endocrine balance and when a
woman fasts for longer than about 12
hours
that hormone kispeptin is significantly
downregulated
resulting in endocrine dysfunction low
energy levels low libido poor ability to
be able to put on muscle or lose fat etc
yet women read a lot of these fasting
books and they say well i'm supposed to
do a 16 hour daily intermittent fast
then they don't feel well after a
certain period of time and
and it turns out that that
pre-menopausal women respond better
to fast intermittent fasts of about 10
to 12 hours in duration
versus men who do better on daily
intermittent fast of 12 to 16 hours in
duration
and the funny thing is that once a woman
is post-menopausal
that flips and that 12 to 16 hour
intermittent fast actually becomes a
good life-extending hack
for a post-menopausal women you know
another example would be
the ketogenic diet that helped your
neighbor to lose
20 pounds for you if you have say
familial hypercholesterolemia or a
poorly functioning
gallbladder so you're not digesting fat
well or you have let's say
an apo e4 gene which would dictate
increased risk of alzheimer's and
dementia and cardiovascular disease
particularly in response to
saturated fats the ketogenic diet is not
going to be
that great of an option for you and so
what i'm getting at here
is that to choose the perfect diet
you're doing to customize and the beauty
is that we live in an era where if you
want to be very data driven
in your approach the same type of test
that would have cost like tens of
thousands of dollars let's say that
you know the princeton longevity
institute a decade and a half ago
you can now do often in the comfort of
your own home
for a fraction of that cost and so
even though in uh in the latter pages of
boundless i have multiple matrices for
about 13 different diets i say okay so
we got that
paleo diet a plant-based diet a
carnivore diet
an autoimmune diet a western a price
diet etc etc
if your bloods look like this if your
jeans look like this
if your urine panel looks like this this
is probably the diet that you should
consider
um you know and granted i think probably
in a few years there'll be enough
ai driven and algorithmic platforms out
there
that allow technology to just spit out
those kind of diets for you
based on on your input and your lab data
and your exercise levels and your body
size etc it shocks me that
something that comprehensive doesn't
exist yet but it doesn't you know it's
still
you know guys like me are just still
spending time pouring through somebody's
labs and telling them how they should
eat but i wish
that a computer could put me out of a
job in that sense because
it'd be far far more
convenient and allow me to be freed up
to do other creative tasks
and so um that being said i think that
uh for for me like if a client comes to
me and they're just like i
you know expenses aside tell me how i
should eat and tell me what tests i need
to get to tell me
how i should eat or how i should
exercise um typically the tests are as
follows
a really good blood panel that's a
little bit more comprehensive
than the basic blood panel your doctor's
gonna run i think uh
the the one i like and the one i use
most is the wellness fx
uh more fancy blood package there's one
i help them design
called the greenfield longevity blood
testing there's one for men
there's one for women it's a very
comprehensive test of basic blood
parameters
like all your lipids all your thyroid um
you know your your uh your white blood
cells your red blood cells
et cetera et cetera so you got your
blood panel
now blood panel often won't tell you a
lot of smaller micronutrients
micronutrients like smaller amino acids
some of the fatty acid balances
etc and so for that there's another test
called a neutroval
that i recommend in addition to that
basic blood panel
so that's what you'd want for blood
would be something like the wellness
effects longevity package
and then a neutral bowel blood test for
hormones
because hormones tend to fluctuate
throughout the day you mentioned the
dutch panel and i actually really like
the dutch panel particularly the one
called the dutch complete
for both neurotransmitter or like brain
neurotransmitter balances
and hormone balances and that's just
peeing on a little p-stick
four to five times during a 24-hour
period and it'll give you melatonin
testosterone estrogen progesterone
dhea everything but a lot more
accurately than a single snapshot blood
test would give you
okay so right that'd be the third
the next would be a very good a gut
panel i like the one by genova
diagnostics
it's a three-day stool panel because
your stool is going it's kind of gross
to think about what's going to fluctuate
in terms of the presence of parasites
and yeast and
fungus and inflammatory markers etc from
day to day
so doing a three-day analysis is more
accurate than a one-day analysis
and that's just a stool kit that's
that's sent to your home you know
you poop in a little hot dog tray and
you
make your loved ones and your families
all nervous as your poop sits there in
the refrigerator in a prepaid fedex bag
waiting to be shipped out you tell
people not to eat the fedex bag
but uh but that but the three-day stool
panel for yeast parasites fungus
bacterial balance in the gut
i actually like that and find it more
meaningful than these fancy
genetic panels for the gut like you know
biome or longevity or
you know that you can get useful that
out of those but we're talking about
dietary prescription
i just like that that three-day gut
panel similar to that for the gut
a really good food allergy panel so that
you don't get a
laundry list of false positives and like
a hundred different foods you're not
supposed to eat because the panel's
inaccurate
but something that's going to test like
the the white blood cell reaction to a
raw
and a cooked version of the protein use
really good data
to actually tell you what you're truly
allergic or intolerant to
is helpful and i like to have that if
i'm working on a nutrition plan for
somebody
white blood cell count goes up and down
versus because of the food that you take
in
yeah there's an immune system reaction
to any food that's why for many people
foods foods that cause an amplified
immune reaction you know like
soy or weed or seeds and nuts etc like
those can be problematic for some people
not all of them
but some of them like i i was going
through some of these tests yesterday
and you know they weren't lit up like a
christmas tree on the food allergy panel
but there were a few
noticeable things on there that were
staples in their diet like
almonds and and shellfish for example
you know for me
i'm pretty clean like i don't have that
big of a food allergy response to
anything except uh oddly enough green
beans and i always thought it was weird
because i never felt that great after i
had green beans
never liked them intuitively that much
always noticed my blood sugar would go
up almost like a stress response to
eating them
and i got tested it turns out i actually
have a true food allergy response
to green beans so i just don't eat those
anymore and
the food allergy panel that i like for
that is called cyrex
c-y-r-e-x and they do they do really
good
food allergy panels so we've got our
blood panel
our micro nutrients blood panel our
our gut test right our food allergy test
our dutch panel and then the the last
one
that i like that i kind of already
mentioned would be like a really good
genetics panel
uh the one i like for that is called
strategy because it'll tell you
everything from
whether or not you are able to you know
use methylated b vitamins properly or
whether you need more methylation
support
how good your nitric oxide pathways are
and whether you should be doing more
like beets arugula
you know sauna things to increase nitric
oxide how good you know like those
glutathione pathways for my boys how
good those are
but again it's not a laundry list of
useless genetic data
it's just like the the nine or so
so-called dirty genes
that you actually should pay attention
to if they wind up to be
issues on your panel so then
most of that data is like emailed to you
in a pdf or delivered to you within a
couple weeks after testing
then you can sit down with that and say
okay so i see that i
have high inflammation i'm low on
vitamin d and magnesium
i have maybe a little bit of a yeast
infection going on in the gut right now
and i'm allergic to almonds and brazil
nuts
and duck and i
uh i've got good testosterone levels but
my progesterone and my dhc are a little
low
so then you could sit down and say okay
well whatever the
type of diet that's going to work well
is let's say a you know a
a paleo autoimmune diet for eight weeks
followed by reintroduction of some of
the problematic foods
and a more all-inclusive diet um and
some support for vitamin d and magnesium
and progesterone and dhea right so
so it's kind of a data-driven process
but in my opinion rather than just like
stabbing in the dark about how you're
supposed to eat the rest of your life
you invest a couple of thousand bucks
and you just know
beyond a shadow of a doubt with
laser-like precision
that what you're eating is actually
customized to optimize
you that all being said
when you look at the blue zones when you
look at areas where people are living a
disproportionately long period of time
you know nikoia and
um sardinia and okinawa and loma linda
and all these
blue zone hot spots around the world you
do see no matter whether they're more
plant-based
no matter whether they're high carb low
fat high fat low carb
no matter you know the type of plants
and herbs and spices that they're using
key characteristics of each of those
populations
that in sort of a venn diagram overlap
no matter what the diet is and those
would include
a some element of fasting and protein
restriction
on certain days of the week or at
certain periods of time during the year
such as a religious fast such as a a
daily
or or weekly like one day where you're
not eating protein or meat
uh perhaps a certain period of time each
spring summer winter and fall
or you might go four to five days eating
a lower calorie diet or doing more of
like a cleanse or a detox
but basically this idea that autophagy
or cellular cleanup or fasting is woven
into
culture as part of the diet we also see
that food is consumed in a
parasympathetic
low stress state chewed very very well
and typically eaten with people in a
celebratory manner
or in a manner in which relationships
are being built big glorious family
dinners
eating mindfully and chewing your food
paying attention as you cook a meal
that you're meditating over it and
generating you know positive energy and
prayers and gratitude over that food
and not you know sucking down a smoothie
while you're speeding down the freeway
at 65 miles an hour
on your way to work right so food is
consumed mindfully
and often in a celebratory fashion with
people
um and then finally uh and there's no
surprises here
you see a relative absence of packaged
and processed foods
right you don't see a lot of trader
joe's or costco or even you know whole
foods a lot of you know gardens and
animals and hunting just eating as close
to nature as possible which i understand
is a little bit more difficult in the
post-industrial era that we were talking
about
but that's beginning questions about
like trying to get back to where we were
and you know the nutrients from the
garden again
right you can use a community supported
agriculture to get some produce
delivered to your house or to local
farmers market
you can do more farmers market than
grocery store you can do a little patio
grow or an indoor pantry grow under some
lights like
once you educate yourself this stuff is
shockingly easy to do i mean like
during covet i got into growing sprouts
from like little
2.99 seed packets i get on amazon
i i could grow organic sprouts for
pennies on the dollar
and have this wonderful unlocked plant
nutrition in my pantry
and it took me like an hour to learn
and after that i'm set for life with
you know uh uh you know a a theoretical
zombie apocalypse friendly food that i
can you know tap into any time
so that's i know it's a long answer to
your question but that's kind of
where to start with nutrition is use
data-driven testing and then once you've
dialed in the diet that's appropriate
for you
borrow from our ancestors and sexually
proven
tactics to enhance the health of any
diet such as fasting
elements of protein restriction eating
with people eating mindfully
celebrating food being grateful for it
and eating as close to nature as
possible
common sense but also there's some stuff
in there that we can go beyond and
really understand and be preventative
which i think
you know in the light of everything
that's happened in the last year i feel
like there's a lot more
of an appetite for prevention and for
awareness uh and taking charge of health
which is when it first hit i thought
that could be the best
one of the best things to come out of
this is people actually looking at
themselves and going how can i take care
of myself
better one thing that i thought of when
you were talking about ancestors and
talking about the way things
were and you know blue zones and and
just you know
some of the things that we've done that
have become creature comforts kind of
like
pre-packaged foods and things like that
is you know the the hot cold
sort of uh you know contrasting is such
a popular thing right now
and i wonder is there a connection
i'm curious about the the actual effects
of it and what's going on and i know
that
there's different sort of uh fat cells
that
are um uh im impacted based on
the hot and the cold but i remember when
i interviewed wim hof and him talking
about how we're just so
we're so conditioned now we're so
unconditioned for weather
like we're we our bodies are just 75 and
sunny every day and we don't
go through the normal experiences that
we used to go through with the cold
coming and the hot and we have air
conditioning and
we're just we're wusses basically was
kind of what he was saying
so is that somewhat of maybe even
i'm this is just a literally like
something that just hit me i wonder if
that has something to do with the hot
and cold stuff that we're doing is that
we're just
we're so far from where we used to be
where you used to be exposed to this
stuff and so we're regaining some of
that
old ability that the body that the body
uh can do to adapt and mitochondria and
everything that gets impacted from it
and then also probably going beyond it
with
a little extra oh yeah i mean there's
great recent books about that like what
doesn't kill us by scott carney
or the comfort crisis by michael easter
and it's this idea that
those things that could kill you in
large amounts
such as sunlight radiation or heat or
excess times in the cold
or excess consumption of some of those
plant defense mechanisms that i was
talking about
they're good for you in small amounts in
microdoses woven throughout the life
right like
20 to 60 minutes of sunlight exposure
each day a deep sweat in a sauna a few
times a week
an intense burst of cold for two to five
minutes in the
morning or in the evening you know
consumption of a wide variety of
plants and herbs and spices but not
necessarily having a whole grocery
shopping cart
full of kale in your blender each
morning you know this idea that
we intelligently expose our bodies to
things that are
mild stressors to induce cellular
resilience when i say induce cellular
resilience i literally mean
increased production of our own
endogenous antioxidants
production of things like heat shock
proteins and cold shock proteins that
protect ourselves from
excesses of stress that go beyond heat
and cold even things like emotional
stress
and lifestyle stress um you know a
formation of almost like a callus on the
skin made of melanin
and tanning pigments that protect us
from uva and uvb radiation
from the sun right there there are all
these responses to the so-called
hermetic stressors that ultimately
make us stronger and heat and cold
are of course two of those and uh you
know i think that we've seen
much research of lake particularly out
of finland that a robust sauna practice
is something that when you isolate for
all confounding variables
uh reduces all cause risk of mortality
uh particularly in men but
you also see this in women uh as well as
reduced risk of dementia
alzheimer's diabetes etc what they don't
tell you i've been to
i've been to to to do sauna ing in
finland many times
you know they're not just in the sauna
they're jumping into the baltic sea you
know the men's finish sauna society and
then back in the sun and into the cold
and so
i think it's more the combination of the
heat in the cold than
just the heat but you know um
i guess since i have to go pretty soon i
should bring this full circle
and say that you know we were talking
about biohacking versus
natural living earlier and i think we've
really highlighted the fact that you can
harness benefits from kind of having one
foot
planted in the realm of ancestral
science and another foot planted in the
realm of of modern science
and i think that combining the two you
know combined both biohacking and
natural living is really ultimately a
good way
to live a long time and feel good doing
it and so if you are
eating healthy based on some of the
nutritional principles and testing that
i've outlined
if you're moving well which we didn't
address but it essentially involves you
know
low level physical activity throughout
the day sometimes lifting heavy stuff
occasionally sprinting whether via
tennis or soccer or
on an air dyne or whatever else and i do
doing some amount of mobility you know
some stretching some foam rolling it's
really not that complex to
to move well i think walking is the most
underrated activity of
all movements but let's assume you're
eating well and you're moving healthy
then i think 90 of the additional
benefit
comes from just charging up your body's
battery you know i'll throw two more
books at you
the body electric by robert becker and
healing is voltage by jerry tennant both
excellent books which dictate the fact
that
as i alluded to earlier when i was
talking about the airplane your cells
operate
with a proper electrochemical balance
across the membrane
your cells operate like a like a battery
with a slight negative charge on the
inside of that membrane
and a slight positive charge on the
outside and there are certain things
that can keep that battery
charged that a lot of people i think who
are eating well
and moving well neglect and that would
be
a good water and mineral intake which
helps to carry these charges such as the
minerals
through your body right so i personally
drink pure clean structured filtered
water
and use copious amounts of really good
minerals not just table salt
right but but really good salts like
celtic salt and black kona salt and
kalima salt and trace liquid minerals so
my body's constantly getting the the
minerals that carry the electrolytes
and the electrical energy into it you
charge up
those electrons with photons of light
from things like
infrared panels or sunlight or an
infrared sauna
you go outside barefoot or get outside
in the ocean or on the beach
with your shoes off or even wearing some
of these grounding or earthing shoes we
talked about or the type of pad that
you're using right now danica
so that you're actually getting exposed
to the negative ions
and electrical impulses from the planet
earth
and then you throw in some heat and some
cold to move this electricity through
your body
and i mean gosh if you if you eat well
eating a diet that's customized to you
you move naturally and then you get uh
water minerals earthing
sunlight heat and cold i guarantee you
you're gonna feel amazing
yeah yeah maybe finish up by giving um
giving us that sort of like level one
version of
say i wanna get up in the morning and i
wanna have
i wanna burn fat i wanna um i wanna feel
energized
i want to work the inside of me a little
bit to recover whatever could be going
on
inside on a cellular level and have
energy
um like what would be sort of the the
movement
and maybe the nutritional consumption
like what would the
what would the morning look like for
someone going to work i'm going to
challenge myself in the next 60 seconds
i'm going to be going to give you the
whole day
wake up take care of your spirit with
some form of
meditation journaling prayer breath work
anything that optimizes that most
important part of you your soul
first while you're in a fasted state go
out
get some sunlight preferably outside do
something for
20 to a maximum of 40 minutes right just
move in that fasted state
come back take a cold shower start your
day
eat your breakfast mindfully take little
breaks throughout the day to walk
to move hang from pull up bars swing
kettlebells
and be productive creative and impactful
with
whatever your your purpose in life is
take a nap in the mid afternoon or a
quick meditation session if you can
to get a little decrease in stress and
cortisol in the middle of the day
continue throughout the day some time
before dinner lift some weights or do a
little high intensity cardio
to get your body ready to be able to
receive food and
burn glucose well have dinner don't be
carb phobic at dinner
eat real food for all your meals but
include some extra carbs at dinner
start to decrease technology screen time
work stress etc
preferably an hour or more before bed
close your eyes in bed return to the
gratitude
the journaling the breath work the care
for your soul
to book end the day and fall asleep wake
up the next day
rinse wash and repeat that's where i
start
thank you i have a feeling that uh that
is still an adjustment for many
probably yeah exactly
well thank you so much your wealth and
knowledge there's there's no way that i
can touch i mean i'm literally like
it so high on the level of caring about
emfs but
your book has everything in it it's all
in there and you've done so many
interviews already
the information is out there i had fun
talking to you thank you very much
thank you so much i have fun talking to
you and um
and maybe i'll have to go back to race
car driving school
and get ready for for round two but i
only want to do it when i'm when i'm
kicking your ass on the racetrack so
any anytime you want to go to the track
i would be happy to
uh i'd be happy to uh to see how that
goes
okay as long as as long as you do it
once in the car and maybe again like a
bicycle or something where i could
actually
potentially have a s at least be
more on level playing ground but that
sounds fair all right
all right cool thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button